In a MOESI protocol,
the state can be M, O, E, S, or I.
Initially, all of the cores have the
block in the I state in their caches.
When C0 reads, it detects that it's
the only one who actually has a copy of
the block, and because it's doing a read
it doesn't go into the modified state,
it goes into the exclusive E state.
The others keep
the block in the I state.
When C1 reads, it detects that it's not
the only one who has the blog,
so it normally goes to S state.
Furthermore, C0 now
snoops another reader, so
it's no longer exclusive and
it moves to the shared state too.
C2 still has the invalid state for
its block.
When C2 reads, it also detects
that there are two other sharers,
so it gets the block
in the shared state.
C1, nothing happens to its shared state.
When we snoop a read, and we are in
the shared state, we just stay there,
because others reading is
compatible with the shared state.
C0 is also in the shared state,
although you were not asked to do this.
And now finally when C1 writes,
because it was in the shared state,
it will put an invalidation
request on the bus, and
once it does that it can
move to the modified state.
Others see that invalidation request and
go to the invalid state.
Pretty much, after our write,
we are always in the modified state,
and all others are always in
the I state at that point.